the Joe Rogan experience it gave them
this unusual platform right and I
thought that means a lot to me to help
people like that's something that's very
very rewarding to me and it's almost all
on the same lines of being able to
provide as a hunter and provide food
like to be a know to provide to let
people know you got to see this guys
guys awesome or even things people that
I even I don't even know people like
their documentary I see a documentary
it's [ __ ] amazing I want to tell
people about it
I like promoting things okay tell and
that without any expectation of
something coming back to me in return I
like I just liked like people say like
oh you know you're doing ads for
products on your Instagram never have
yeah everything that I've ever put up on
Instagram unless it's my own stuff
unless it's like my fanny packs or
something I sell anything that I've ever
put on like people accused me of like
working for Vibrams for I finger shoes
Makhno I liked them right I liked them I
don't want anything from them you know
this is I wear them all time this is why
I think they're good I think they build
your feet up I know my feet are stronger
because I run with these things yeah
[ __ ] chill like no that's not what
I'm doing and it's like that's the one
thing of having financial independence
that's yeah it's really rewarding is
that I don't have to think like that ya
know like I've been offered to do ads on
Instagram I'm like I can't because
unless I said molest was something are
super believed in yeah then I might I
might consider doing it but I could
never do it with some nonsense like
coca-cola or something like that because
that's Guinea tea
what's that Guinea tea what skinny tea I
see the girls do it what a skinny tea
young kids oh he's got what's that
called again what do you know what's
going on he's a little liaison
no no no but he's a did Duncan say it
wherever he kept saying it when you know
it's like popular oh what's the term I I
have was we talked about at dinner yeah
I don't remember
doubles Duncan just kept going on about
Lil B I know it would be the base case
also sale
cuz Gucci it's like the kids knew and
Mike there's a word zeitgeist yes yes so
that's Jamie yeah
Jamie's I'm not a zeitgeist B I know
about this floating Jamie is online all
day and he's just ever ever since the
Eddie Bravo podcast has been blocking
people yeah it's always a blocking
rampage that's that's like most so what
is skinny T what is that it's like detox
tea it's like a thing that people
promote they post a picture I drink my
tea every day and it's making detoxing
yeah well wasn't that thing you were
telling me that Gary Vee was saying that
you know you can get a lot of money for
your Instagram posts yes I saw like on a
Good Morning America thing he did that
if you have a hundred thousand followers
I believe you can get up to about five
thousand dollars per post
that's crazy of a million a ramp ramp
subway hike 20 grand there there was
this 40 grand post yeah I changed my
tune
I'm gonna sell out now I'm offering my
services to anything that sucks there's
this girl and I can't remember who what
she was in a movie camp she's sort of
cute but kind of unique looking she was
getting 65,000 an Instagram post and
20,000 a story post what yeah she said
she bought a house for doing wingman I
need to sell out you do what do i what
do I sell out to who do I saw to anybody
everyone Vibrams how much money you got
you know I've been promoting you for
free yet the only thing I would ever
promote is I died it's like the same
thing I feel about the stuff that I
promote for free yeah it would have to
be something that I like believed in
yeah but after you like like Hoyt if
Hoyt came to me and said we I'm wearing
a Hoyt hat you are if you would you
promote our balls I'm like [ __ ] yeah I
shoot him every day
they're awesome yeah they they actually
put your picture up being you beautiful
yeah put it up
[Applause]